uh why don't we keep it going it's hard
to imagine we could keep such a streak
going today
but i'm really gonna try let's go to
and i know that last time i
mispronounced your name is it
tamesha from new york city
yes tamisha how are you hi how are you
um david do you know why i like you so
much
no i i'm shocked you do to be honest
no i like you because i think of things
and i see things happening and then
i go to watch a video of yours and you
think
exactly are similar to the way i think
okay
but um i wanted to ask you a question
about um
i know that there's been a policy in the
talks about
free college i know biden was talking
about community colleges being free
yeah and um i know some people talk
about state colleges
and when i talk to my friends about it i
say oh my son who's 11
by time he goes to college it'll be free
and when we talk about like college
funds
but then they tell me that um college is
only free for like the really really
poor is that true
that it won't be like everybody has
access to that
well the thing the thing that's
difficult to mesha is that we don't know
yet because there are proposals uh there
are proposals for
full free state college regardless of
income
there are proposals for means-tested
programs where
if family income is above a certain
amount
then it's not free but below that amount
it is free but what i will tell you is
this every proposal i've seen
from any any serious democrat
would be at least free community college
below very re it won't only be for
people
under the federal poverty line it won't
be that it'll be free for a significant
portion of the population the real
question is will this pass
i have no idea we just don't know yet
for now there's you know nothing has
passed
so if it were me right now and i don't
have a kid right now
to save for college i would be operating
financially under the assumption that
college would not be free for them and
hey you know what if it ends up being
free
that's great well yeah i guess i'm being
optimistic
yeah of course i do agree with you that
you should plan
for any outcome yes but um
and i think i find like the fact that it
wouldn't be like that the income
part of it bothers me only a little bit
because you know most people
even if you have a decent salary you
still fall and you're still not
necessarily rich
of course you know um even if you have a
decent salary and those people still
tend to be forgotten no doubt and this
was an issue sometimes
you know with with obamacare in many
states the way that the subsidies are
set
there's no i don't remember what state
it was but there are states where the
subsidies if you're a self-employed
person and you have to go and buy
a plan on the mark healthcare market you
get a
really big subsidy if you earn under 10
000 a year
and a smaller subsidy between 10 and 20
and a smaller subsidy between 20 and 30
but like by the time you get to 48 000
a year the subsidy ends so basically if
you earn 48
000 a year 88 000 a year
or 888 000 a year everybody gets no
subsidy once you get to 48.
that seems terrible it's that middle
that really gets squeezed in that
situation
and so something to be aware of and and
let's hope that it doesn't happen if
indeed there's a college funding plan
put put together
yes hopefully yeah and one more thing um
i know you talked about this a week or
so ago two weeks maybe
about the mayor in chicago i think it
was where she was
saying that she would only um
she would only be interviewed by
non-white journalists
yeah and like i agree with you where i
feel like if you
discrim if you are calling out
discrimination by using discrimination
and that's not only hypocritical but it
defeats the purpose
yes but i also from another perspective
i think i i'm only guessing i can't
speak for her but i'm thinking that
since you know the history of blacks in
this country is where we're seen as
um less than we're seen as um
not human we were in the past or were
seen as
uh as stupid lazy like those are some of
the stereotypes
i think that that um what she was trying
to do or what maybe she's trying to do
is say
we're we're trying to i'm trying to even
the playing field and give us an upper
hand
upper hand yeah and to clarify on that
tamesha for people who don't know
chicago mayor lori lightfoot said that
around i don't remember if it was just
like around memorial day or what it was
she said that she was only going to be
interviewed by
non-white journalists for this period
short period of time
and interview requests by white
journalists would be rejected now what i
said at the time was
if this is just a policy this is this is
just racism i'm against it completely
however if it had been presented as hey
you know what
this is a city the city of chicago which
has a huge non-white population
and yet most of the interviews with
elected officials that show up in the
newspapers are with white journalists so
for this one week i am going to
prioritize being interviewed
by journalists of color great
beautiful however the way that it was
said was i will be rejecting interview
requests from white journalists and
and you know what i just think it was it
was completely improperly framed and i
agree with you that there's a right way
to do this and there's a wrong way to do
this
yeah and that's basically what is trying
to figure out the right way yeah to
give us an even playing field because
most of the time what what um black
people are asking for is equality not
necessarily a handout
right we take it it's just to even the
playing field
i'm with you i'm with you that's not
really always the right way to do it i
agree with you
all right tamesha always great to hear
from you
thank you all right there is tamisha uh
let's take a quick break if you're
holding
don't hang up we're going to try to keep
the streak of perfect phone calls going
right after this short break